first lady senator Portman and his wife
congressman Turner and his daughter and
Senator and I went to visit victim those
of the shooting
as well as folks that have been injured
had been discharged were there as and
also the first responders who without
their heroic actions hundreds would have
hundreds would have died we reiterated
to the president the importance of
action around these issues and guns and
that the people of Dayton are waiting
for action from the Washington DC we
talked a bit to the chief of staff it
was also there about red flag law and
how there's a certain legislation that
Lindsey Graham and Blumenthal are moving
to make sure that we can have our
national red flag law and there's a
piece in that legislation that would
actually make Ohio and Texas be a pilot
their cities to be able to go right to
the federal courts for it so I
reiterated that and then the senator was
very eloquent about
on Sunday like to be afternoon with the
mayor police chief there's some of the
first responders that save lives we saw
some of them today so we met all the
police officers who unquestionably saved
the lives of dozens and dozens and
dozens of people in the organ both of us
spoke with the president right when he
got off Air Force One both the mayor and
I asked the president to call on Senator
McConnell to move to bring the Senate
back in session this week to tell the
Senate that he wants the background
checks bill that has already passed the
house that he wants it on the floor I
asked the president to promise to me and
to the American people that he will sign
that bill after he's spoken out in
support of it with Senator McConnell was
only said that we will get things done I
then later asked the President to I said
if you care about mental health people
consistently say well it's not guns it's
mental health well it is mostly that
it's mostly too many guns on the street
when I said you know
or there was if he cares about mental
health that is essential because
Medicaid matters so much the last thing
that I said to the president before he
left we have just met police officers
officers you can do for these police
officers is take these assault weapons
off the streets so they don't have to go
weapons mayor how would you characterize
your conversation with the president do
you feel like he was hearing you I think
he heard me
I don't know if he will take action I'm
hoping for the people of Dane that he
does but we you know both the senator
and I spoke very directly what we've
been saying the whole time about the
need for common-sense gun legislation
senator the mass shootings have been
politicized Democrats and Republicans
pointing the finger at each other don't
both parties take blame in the inability
to find a solution to these mass
shooting no no there been mass shootings
under political ads with my tell me why
you believe it
well there been mass shootings and are
both Democrat and Republican
administrations Republicans for three
years now
and done the bidding of the NRA the
National Rifle Association the gun lobby
gives millions of dollars to Republican
candidates and spends millions and
millions against Democrats like me they
could get an F from the NRA they've
stood up to the NRA we can't get
anything done in the Senate because
Mitch McConnell the president United
States are in bed with the gun lobby
there's a lot of things we could work on
to make this work better the guns is a
big big part of this certainly mental
health services matter but the same
people that say it's mental health it's
not too many guns on the street are the
same people that try to cut Medicaid and
the same people that try to repeal the
Affordable Care Act so be honest about
this guns is a big big part of this and
we have a whole political party in this
country now with the exception of
congressman Turner I went had now who's
been on the right side that it's in bed
with the gun lobby you can call it
gridlock but it's because of that swap
that has a lock of the senator both you
and the mayor have been critical of this
president before and in fact you senator
initially you were not going to meet
with the president he changed your mind
I'm just wondering a lot of the American
people feel as though we've been here
before we've heard all this before we've
been in this situation
in the past did either of you hear
anything at all that would lead you to
lead you to believe that this time
something might be different I changed
my mind and large becoming I didn't want
in any way encouraged the president's
racist talk in divisive talk I came
because mayor Whaley asked me to come
and I came because I thought maybe I'd
have a chance to talk to the president
okay can I get a chance to talk to the
president about pushing putting pressure
when Senator McConnell - they an assault
weapons which Congress did for ten-year
period once ly partisan ly and to get
the president because if the president
tells the Congress pass an assault
weapon ban if the president says pass
legislation for universal background
checks the Republican Congress in the
Senate will move on it in the house will
undoubtedly I bet you command we can do
then yes I mean this this for us Dayton
we hope so I'm not holding my breath you
know too often we just see complete
inaction because they're waiting just
for time for people to forget that nine
people died in Dayton because of a gun
that was - that shouldn't be it
shouldn't be legal frankly you know we
pointed out I pointed out to the
president that government now governor
former senator Mike DeWine voted for the
assault weapons ban if there was a time
when this was bipartisan and so we're
looking for those people in Congress to
come together because the majority of
Americans agree so this should be an
action do I think that we're gonna see
another mass shooting tomorrow or Friday
probably because Washington will not
move when you looked in his eyes that
you seem like someone who was ready to
take action or did he seem like someone
who was just gonna let this as you said
look died down this is the first time I
met the president so I don't think my
ability to look in his eyes is gonna
give you any insight on what he's
thinking
I'm sorry no no I mean the conversation
that the airport was pretty brief you
know he was kind of moving pretty
quickly to uh towards us and it was like
you know mr. president the city of
Dayton and the people of Dayton really
are looking forward to some action
that's what you can do to help us is to
get some action no I talked to us I mean
I I'm very concerned about it president
plays the races rhetoric in his racist
night I remember President Bush who I
agreed with about very little wanted to
privatize Social Security he lied about
the Iraq war but after September 11
President Bush went to a mosque and said
Muslims didn't attack the United States
terrorists in President Obama after the
two most awful shootings of all the
shootings sandy in Charleston went to
comfort them and talked healing talked
insane healing language I wish this
president would do that we did not talk
about that we talked about Medicaid and
getting Congress to move I don't know
the president intimately but I will
continue to call he was comforting they
did the right things and Melania did the
right things and it's his job in part to
comfort people
I think it was a good decision for him
not to stop at the Edition but look I
mean I think how many of you were here
for the Sunday vigil any of you any okay
so you saw just some of the anger and
agitation in our community about it I
think a lot of people that are owned
businesses in that district aren't
interested in the president being there
and you know a lot of the time his talk
can be very divisive and that's the last
thing we need to do you feel about your
I've been I've been proud of it I mean I
haven't paid a lot of attention to the
response today so you might know
something I don't know so like the
senator and I literally just got back
from the hospital we didn't have cell
phone like cell phone service and they
came right here so I would say that if
someone who doesn't live in Dayton and
admires the mayor so much I would say
this community has been extraordinary
from from the night it happened with the
police to the rescue people that showed
up from all the suburbs by from the city
another 15 from suburbs got there within
20 minutes the people at the hospital
were terrific and people showed when the
president states came they showed
respect for the office and a number of
them said to me they're not great
admirers of him privately but they
clearly showed respect for the office
because the president United States is
in town that's one of the reasons I'm
here but
to the mayor's request but I think this
town has been just extraordinary from
the KKK rallies to the rally to what
happened in the tornado and here oh you
tell me they're all in senator Portman
about about what you did today and
whether or not you two will work
together I'm trying to do it maybe it's
not Robin I can talk substance today
about these issues we talk for a moment
about our work intentions it wasn't a
time good relationship we differ on the
issue of guns we hope we can find some
common ground on this but so far so far
we haven't mayor what can we tell us
about what you would tell people about
the oregon district and in terms of
suburbs in terms of people from across
state being willing to go back there
after this after this you know the next
few days of coverage dies down right we
want people to come in and this is the
local spot these are local business
owners with local restaurants so you
know we want people to come and really
support the district will be having some
activities over the coming months for
people to come down and larger and
larger forms don't hear more about that
later but the best thing you can do is
you know number one you can donate to
the Dayton fund and the day foundation
for those both those victims that have
been hurt number two you can call the
President and senator Portman and thank
congressman Turner for action around
guns and also your state legislature
because the DeWine the DeWine stuff is
coming so there will be movement there
so you know calling calling calling
about I'm from Dayton and I want action
on this will be very important and then
number three you can support our local
businesses and
in districts so those are three things
that people can do really easily I think
the white is known for maybe almost any
place of state do you have any plans to
meet with the different plans to meet
with the Beth's family have you reached
out to them what are you know you know
they're a victim family too because of
Meghan and so we have victim advocates
for every single family you know they
you know know very well that they want
to reach out to us were there in a
heartbeat but we know how tough this is
for families and so we're giving them
the space I do plan on going to some of
the visitations in the final weeks what
do you think before we make matches that
burnt out in the Oregon district this
morning to think resident come
supporters and protestors I can't really
comment on it because I haven't seen it
yet so okay we got one more question
senator you're calling on Mitch
McConnell through the call us and in
fact it's in Sunday any progress on that
front end with Portman saying that gives
us consensus on the issue of expanded
background checks are you confident
there are gonna pass something like that
I have said it repeatedly some sunny
soon after I called man and decided to
come to Dave right away
a national show and call the McConnell
to do that I talked to Senator Schumer
since then he's on board a number of
Democrats have now come back I would see
no action yet McConnell's got a break
his addiction to drug company money to
break his addiction to gun lobby money
and he hasn't seemed